le porte-parole du ministère chinois des
Affaires étrangères tentent de se faire
rassurant
tous les pays passent par une période de
transition lorsqu'ils ajustent leur
politique covid la Chine ne fait pas
exception actuellement à la situation
épidémique en Chine et tout à fait
prévisible et maîtrisé
mais de plus en plus d'hôpitaux sont
saturés la Chine est au prise avec la
pire vague de covid 19 en 3 ans alors
qu'elle a laissé tomber sa politique
zéro covid ce sont surtout des personnes
âgées qui se retrouvent en détresse
comme ici dans cet hôpital de cngine
pour réduire le nombre de visites en
personne personnelle médical ici réalise
les consultations en ligne avec les
patients
j'ai eu 80 rendez-vous en une journée
les plages horaires se remplissent
rapidement explique cette médecin
les États-Unis se disent préoccupés par
le manque de transparence des données
chinoises ils exigeront un test covid au
voyageur venant de la Chine tout comme
l'Italie le Japon l'Inde et Taïwan les
États-Unis et d'autres pays parlent
d'imposer des tests spéciales à l'entrée
c'est une possibilité pour essayer de
les trier ce qu'on sait aussi c'est que
ceux qui ont été infectés et qui ont eu
au moins deux à trois doses de vaccins
sont habituellement très bien protégés
il y aurait 37 millions de cas par jour
et les pharmacies sont frappées par une
pénurie de médicaments les entreprises
pharmaceutiques augmentent leur capacité
de production et de distribution
cette semaine la demande est forte pour
les médicaments contre la toux une
équipe spéciale est attitrée à la
production de médicaments anticoïdes ici
Mélissa François Radio-Canada Montréal